well are humans the only species that
have has language it's a question that's
been asked many times but to think about
it I'd like you to imagine a dog and
he's a very thoughtful dog and he can
hear humans barking he can hear that
amongst the funny noises humans make
there are a number of signals with fixed
meanings like a walkies sit heel and he
ponders as to whether the rest of the
noise they make is just barking or
whether it constitutes a language and I
fix from that idea I mean obviously it's
a silly fable but it's not completely
silly in that precisely because we do
not understand the noises that dogs make
except for a few individual signals such
as you know let me out of here or take
me for a walk or there's an intruder we
therefore say it's not a language
because it consists only of a a
discreetly a fixed number of specific
signals that don't change and the rest
is just dog barking dogs could in this
fable have exactly the same
understanding of human language the
problem is that we can't translate
between dog and human if we could then
we might know whether dogs have a
language or not
all right the condition for the
existence of a language of what we think
of as a language is its translate
ability so the boundary between our
species and others is indeed an
unbridgeable gulf until we learn to
translate them if we could translate any
of them we would then have a much more
intelligent interesting view as to what
makes human language different from but
there's no earthly reason I mean given
that language as I've said at the
beginning is a form of human behavior
why a dog or a cow should have a human
form of behavior they're not humans
so that it's the species different you
know what would I want to say anyway
will be of interest to us only a limited
number of things where we interact on
specific points and so the argument that
only human languages language and that
animal communication systems however
sophisticated they are and some of them
are quite sophisticated are not
languages because they consist of
discrete signals is a kind of it's a
circular argument it's a self-fulfilling
thing and I think we should be a little
bit more interested in the complexity
and the variability of animal
communication systems and less rigid
about this distinction between what is a
language and what is not a language